thank you very much Joan for that
slightly
misleading introduction to um someone
who may no longer be a socialist but
still vibrates to Marxism uh thank you
ladies and gentlemen for coming I think
I'll be able to be reasonably tur given
the very heavy artillery that follows me
on our side I think it might perhaps
have been felt when I was chosen that
the case for atheism should not be made
by the spokesman for its moderate Wing
Richard
Dawkins um it might be okay to have at
least one extremist on the panel um and
I'll begin uh At Once by recalling an
exchange I had recently in Colorado
Springs with a spokesman of
America's Evangelical broadcasting
Wing a much overrated but nonetheless
significant force in American po
politics this broadcaster asked me in
response to my own statement of unbelief
he said I insist that you answer the
following question and that you answer
it with a yes or a no I braced myself I
accepted the challenge unseen he said
you want to imagine yourself in a
strange city where you've never been
before you are to imagine Nightfall
coming on and you to be without friends
or sucker in this town and you to you
are to ask yourself whether you would
feel safer or less safe when you saw a
dozen men coming towards you in the
dusk if you were to know that they had
recently come from a prayer
meeting this is the I'm I'm I'm I think
I can justifi we say I'm relaying to you
comrades friends brothers sisters the
challenge that was put by the religious
to me you'll see at once it's not a yes
no answer you can't give a yes no answer
to that but I accept it anyway I said
very well I won't give a Sesame Street
reply but just without leaving the
letter B I have been in that situation
in Bombay in Belfast in Beirut in
Belgrade in Baghdad and many other
places too and I won't tell you about
all of them but let me just let me just
as it were fill in some of those uh
latent uh
blanks um in Belfast the capital city of
one of the provinces of this our United
Kingdom as everybody here
knows everything culturally
educationally
economically politically socially has
been very Gravely for at least
a quarter of a century excuse me at
least half a century maybe more since
partition and before that because
partition is both the uh outcome and the
cause of sectarian Warfare in this town
by the simple fact that there are people
there who are willing to kill not just
one another another but one another's
children on the basis of what kind of
Christian they
are horrible things are done not just in
pubs and clubs but on the streets on
housing Estates uh on University
campuses uh in that City still despite
the relatively good news we've had uh
today where the situation remains
dominated by barbaric sectarian Party
leaders on this and no other basis uh
both churches demand that their children
are sent to separate schools they each
agree with the other that Above All
Things their own children must be
protected from the faith of another
Faith uh I don't think I need to
elaborate very much more on uh how
horrendous the consequences of that have
been and how they are enshrined by the
way in our own Constitution which
mandates that our own head of the
church is uh also the head of the state
and of the the Armed
Forces um with all the ludicrous Windsor
consequences that you get if you found a
National Church on the family values of
Henry
VII these conditions which are faral in
England Wales and Scotland are tragic
and ugly only a few minutes flying time
from where we sit if I pass on from
Belfast to say Baghdad where I've
recently been and without reopening any
of the arguments about the rightness or
otherwise of of the Coalition
intervention in Mesopotamia I think it
can be granted by any fair-minded person
that what was most needed in Iraq after
30 years of fascism and War was a period
of
reflection a short interlude of
calm during which Iraqis could look
about themselves and decide perhaps whom
they'd like to vote perhaps what kind of
country they'd like to live in what kind
of federal system they might wish to
evolve and to do so unmolested by
violence or Terror the parties of God
have the repoed every hope of that
process the parties of God now have the
Iraqi people in their jaws and they're
saying to them it's not enough just to
kill foreigners or to rail against Jews
uh or Christians or secularists that's
nothing like enough uh it's only in Iraq
uh not only mainly chiefly in Iraq that
it's considered perfectly all right in
fact a religious Duty uh to blow up the
mosques to destroy the religious schools
of other Muslims of the Muslims of
another school not unlike the pattern of
Belfast it's not enough to have faith
you must have the right version of your
own faith or risk death mutilation and
humiliation and the the
destruction the am miseration the
torture of Iraqi Society is something
that all of us can read about every day
suppose we're to go to Beirut the pearl
of the Levant uh the most civilized and
and beautiful and cultured uh City of
the Middle East to see what happens when
for for politicized reasons a sectarian
Constitution is in place which says that
the president of of Lebanon must always
be a marinite Christian that the speaker
of its Parliament must always be a Shia
that its vice president must always be a
Sunni that the DRS must have their share
and so on leaving out at the very bottom
I'm afraid such forces as Kurds and
Armenians but making everyone defined in
their citizenship by their faith do I
need to elaborate what that's done to
to bankrupt to beggar to
disfigure and to degrade what could have
been an ideally plural and diverse and
happy
Society uh remaining with letter B shall
I say baluca shall I say Belgrade or
just say
Bosnia again one of the most civilized
enclaves of the Balkans for many years
protected by a secular Constitution and
the the remains of what had been a
secular and Democratic Republic and just
look what happens when it is decided
that it is that it is a matter of faith
that determines your citizenship Your
Allegiance uh your identity your nature
your rights see the recrudescence in the
Europe of the late 20th and early 21st
century of Catholic fascist parties we
thought we'd left behind at nurenberg
the
ustasa the recrudescence of forces uh
like the chetniks the Serbian
Orthodox uh fascists who took the
exactly the same view except the other
way around see the Craven Way in which
our spinalis media which always defers
to people of Faith say that it was serbs
who shelled Saro or croats who shelled
Musta when what they should have been
saying was today the Christian Orthodox
militia bombarded an open City around
the clock or yesterday the Catholic
forces shelled mustar From Dawn Till DUS
they didn't do it because it's a matter
of time taste we're supposed to respect
people of faith and we're supposed to
respect them while they do that and do
that and make this sort of
excuse uh there are there aren't enough
words in my lexicon at any rate to
express the contempt that I think any
right thinking person must feel for this
conscription of this kind of medieval
barbarism um Joan will tell me when I've
got a minute I don't know how whether
I'm yet trespassing on my um my rivals
and my allies time but um if I was to
add
Bombay to this list the city that was
very nearly ruined by the sectarian
partition of India in 1947 1948 where
once again people were told it's a
matter of Faith what kind of Indian you
are you may have to become a Pakistani
if you're Muslim you may have to lose
your life on the proposition you may not
just be a Hindu uh B Bombay more or less
survived this the terrifying ethnic
cleansing and the pogram uh that ensued
when the subcontinent was mutilated and
maimed in part partitioned on on this
basis in the hopes of a genuine Indian
unity and Independence ruined by way of
appeasement of of people of Faith but
Bombay sort of recovered until recently
when now its name has been changed uh
its minority citizens persecuted
intimidated driven out by a new Hindu
nationalist uh party the shiv Senna that
says that again if you don't if you do
not follow the right God if you don't
accept the supernatural as a real force
in everyday life you are not worth uh
what whatever it takes to become or to
remain or be treated as an ordinary
Democratic civilized human being in
again one of the great cities of
Asia now it's not part of my case and
I'm sure it's not part of Professor
grings or Professor Dawkins is either to
say that religion is the reason for all
of this or the exclusive or sole reason
for all of it I think it would be crude
and reductionist to say that but who is
going to argue I'll be f fascinated to
see who is going to argue that the
matter of Faith the religious allegiance
that the preachings of religion have not
in all these cases Gravely exacerbated
Gravely deepened Gravely poisoned and
prolonged all of these things that have
made our tenuous civilization extremely
difficult to defend uphold maintain let
alone to advance I don't believe this
case could be made that's for a simple
reason because religion is not provided
to us by Revelation it doesn't come from
the heavens
it doesn't come from the Beyond it
doesn't come from the Divine it's
man-made and it
shows it shows very well that religion
is created invented imposed by a species
half a chromosome away from the
chimpanzee it shows doesn't it well why
do we deceive ourselves on this point
and is there anywhere now going to wind
up is there anywhere of the of the
places I've mentioned and I exempt bazer
and all the other bees I could take you
around where it wouldn't be enormously
welcome if there was a mass conversion
to secularism or a mass adoption of the
secular idea and principle of the
principles of beron Russell who once
spoke famously from this platform of
Thomas Payne of Thomas Jefferson of
voler and and others and I'll close by
saying that I want you to be on your
guard against two false issues in this
respect and I'll be very brief um when I
mentioned those gentlemen
and I could mention some ladies too in
this connection like Mary walon CRA
don't let anyone tell you that oh well
secular tyranny is just as bad after all
there's been fascist and communist
dictatorships which have been just as
revolting fascism as you know was
supported by the Catholic Church all
through its life and in fact till after
it had died and still is defended by it
one of the leaders of the axis was
actually the Japanese leader was
actually a god there's no way of saying
Fascism and national socialism on the
axis was secular and in the case of
stalinism and maoism and the K Rouge the
same mistake is made and a religion is
made out of man it's the religious
impulse itself that I think we need to
oppose to criticize to criticize in
ourselves as well as in others the
argument from faith in other words the
argument from certainty so those of us
who maintain this may not be described
my closing Point as fundamentalists or
secularists as certain cheap and
demagogic and opportunist forces have
recently been suggested we do believe in
evidence we do believe in skepticism we
do believe in reason we hold our views
we hold our views with as much
conviction and Principle as any God
botherer does but we are open to the
argument and we're going to prove it
tonight to you and don't let anyone dare
to imply there's a moral equivalence
between us and the Fanatics and the
fools and those who think they know
God's Will and can tell you what it is
who are our enemies and your enemies too
so I beg to propose the motion that
stands in our name thank
[Music]
you yeah there a lot more than nine
yeah the motion is opposed by Dr Nigel
Spivey who is a teacher of classical art
and archaeology at Cambridge his books
which are many include songs on bronze
Greek myths R told and he has done
several television series of which one
was called digging for Jesus Dr
Spivy the proposer of the motion began
by saying he was putting the case for
atheism and with respect Christopher I
I'm going to start by saying this isn't
a debate about the existence of
God it's a debate about us us Mortals
The Crooked Timber of humanity and how
the practice of religion in general
affects
us KL Marx famously described religion
as an opiate Jonathan Miller thinks it's
more of an amphetamine gets people over
excited and my own meager uh religious
experience disposes me to think of it as
a sort of anesthetic by which I mean
that when I am s situations of feeling
lonely sad or frightened uh I find
myself cuning hymns hymns that really
relate to the place where we are they're
mostly Wesley and hymns but anything
really that has the sentiment of Psalm
23 uh and helps one whistle and sing
through the valleys of fear and death
but I'm not here to testify as a
somewhat lapsed
Methodist but instead to deliver such
academic expertise as I have to to offer
on this topic it's brief has to be brief
but in my view it is so
compelling that when we arrive at the
conclusion in six minutes
time I'm half afraid that everyone will
walk
out and I'd like you to promise not to
do that otherwise this will be um an
embarrassment uh to the organizers and
to
ourselves I'm going to talk about
archaeology and
anthropology and start with the news
from archaeology the long-term
view as far is that a better as far as
we can tell the species of homo sapiens
roamed the world for thousands of years
before becoming as it were religious
something radical happened in our minds
our cognitive systems about 40,000 years
ago we started to make things for the
sake of beauty not utility we started
painting pictures carving sculptures we
started using symb symbols and that
probably included talking to to each
other uh making music painting our
bodies and so
on this is referred to by archaeologists
as the creative
explosion and it's a consensus that
there's this kind of grand Collective
takeoff of our human capacities in the
Stone Age or the upper Paleolithic to be
precise and one aspect here I think I
ought to highlight which is that
one of the features that appears at this
time 40,000 years ago is that humans
start burying each other properly and
they start with these burials to put
down flowers gifts and other signs of
what we take to be some kind of Sucker
or consolation and possibly a belief in
an afterlife there is some debate about
whether our doomed Rivals and the
andales had these sensibilities but the
consensus is that Homo sapiens is a
species uniquely
hardwired for
metaphysics I've written about this in
an understated book called How Art made
the world and I'm not going to go on uh
anymore about it but this archaeological
evidence for the Genesis of art religion
and culture in the creative development
of homo sapiens is not easily discounted
and it sets up an evolutionary
pattern it explains why I think think
when John lenon or Richard Dawkins asks
us to imagine a world without religion
you find your mind wandering and you're
wondering what a world would look like
without King's College Chapel without
the Taj Mahal without haa Sophia the
Blue Mosque the pathon the pantheon the
cine
Chapel Venice I've got down here and I
think just about all of Venice
qualifies and you become aware that even
while n in the 1880s was declaring in
that God was dead the same time you've
got vano manically ding away out of
religious fervor and a little later on
that uh you find Kandinsky more cooly
explaining why this Nexus of art music
and
spirituality uh made such an essential
and indisoluble Alliance for uh our
quest for transcendental
satisfaction and it's why when I'm asked
to imagine a world without religion it
does tend to end up looking
like dare I say a suburb of Swindon with
the only with the only Spire the only
Spire that pierces the sky is the
Tesco's
clock well we've got a few minutes for
the anthropology um here as well once
upon a time there was a Classics uh don
at Cambridge who sat in his study and he
compiled a voluminous series of case
studies gathered from around the
colonized world World about how
pre-industrial societies kept up
peculiar and primitive practices so they
cowered when the Thunder started rolling
they danced for rain they would copulate
in the fields to ensure a good harvest
and so
on it's a literary Masterpiece this work
by JG Fraser the golden bow subtitled a
study in Magic and religion and in
Fraser's words it set out to chart the
Long March the slow and toysome Ascent
of humanity from savagery to
civilization beautifully
written but it's all TSH and most
anthropologists would say so today in
fact it was um not an anthropologist but
another Cambridge individual Ludwick
wienstein
who made some remarks offhand as it
seems about Fraser's golden bow and
pointed out that Fraser's method was
fundamental fundamentally mistaken he
supposed Fraser supposed that Savages
these so-called Savages made their
sacrifice to grave and Idols or they
danced for rain out of ignorance and
Superstition but as Vicken Stein argued
the essence of ritual is performance
it's
expressive it's something that you can't
gloss with a reasonable explanation in
Vicken Stein's word we can only describe
and say human life is like
this um have I got time for an analogy
one minute probably not time for the
analogy I was going to tell you about
the risks of attempting to react
violently to a computer when it does
something stupid which is based on the
analogy that Vicken Stein gives of
hitting the ground when you're angry
it's not because you think you're going
to hurt the ground it's because you want
a release of Rage I will just briefly
incidentally say that it is a very bad
idea to hit a
laptop William James the American
psychologist showed a century ago that
there is no logical connection to be
made between the fact that our ancient
ancestors made errors of scientific
reasoning mix them up with their
religion and the conclusion that all
religion is a big mistake logically that
just does not
work if I had another hour here I'd like
to expatiate on the extraordinary
phenomenon of how one religion overlaps
with another and how especially the
Persistence of sacred behavior from the
Pagan to the classical world uh is
something you know the U trees and the
churches the roots of the cult of the
virgin in Antiquity and so on but I'm
going to end up by saying that around
the world whatever we say here tonight
around the world the Sea of Faith rolls
on it rolls on because faith is not some
kind of atavistic relapse but part of
our creative and ingenious nature it's a
force by which we humans survive and the
conclusion is that this fact is attested
archaeologically anthropologically
psychologically and I dare say
neurologically and the conclusion would
be that for the next hour or so can I
tell you this in a sense we are wasting
our time debating that we'd be better
off without religion it's not an option
religion is part of our human makeup and
it's going to be a very interesting uh
time that we spend but essentially it's
not a topic for debate it's the way that
we
are